He is the epitome of pure,
unadulterated evil,
the mastermind gallery with the swastika on his forehead and the wild crazed
look in his eyes.
He is responsible for one of the most heinous crimes of our time,
controlling his minions like puppeteer.
In this week's buying graphics.
We're looking into the dark and disturbing story of Charles Manson.
Charles Mills Manson was born on November the twelfth and Nineteen 34 to 16 year
old Kathleen Maddox and the 24 year old tranzians labor known only as Colonel
Scott.
Kathleen was a promiscuous teenager who drank too much and earns money to fuel
their habits by selling her body.
The baby was known as new name Maddix for the first few weeks of life until his
mother seemed to settle on Shawnee.
He never knew his father.
He cleared out as soon as he heard the Kathleen was pregnant.
Kathleen was too young,
too immature,
and unpredictable to provide a stable environment for a young child.
She appeared to have new maternal instincts and would leave the trial to fend
for himself while she went off on one of our vendors.
As an adult.
Charlie often related to that his mother was once in a cafe with him on her knee
when the waitress offered to buy the baby from her.
Kathleen's asking price was a pitcher of beer and having consumed as she simply
walked out and left Charlie to the women.
According to Charlie,
his uncle took four days to track him down and return him home.
When Charlie was six years old,
his mother and uncle decided to rob a gas station.
They were both caught,
convicted and sent for five years to Moundsville state prison.
The boy was putting into the have is strictly religious grandparents,
but after a few months he went to live with his aunt and uncle in West Virginia.
The environment was very different to anything.
Shawnee had previously known his aunt.
His sister was regimens in disciplines.
She was also strictly religious.
Her husband's build was even more fervent in his faith and his wife,
a strict disciplinarian.
He considered jolly to be a sissy.
On the first day of school,
he said the boy to class and address in order to teach him how to fight.
Shawnee seemed adapt it to this very different kind of life and actually grew to
enjoy his new regimented routine for two years,
between six and eight would prove to be some of the most stable of his young
life,
but then his mother was released from prison and immediately took him back.
Gasoline was more unstable than ever.
She preferred a life of promiscuity and alcohol abuse to botanical,
domesticity,
constantly in trouble with the law runs with no money for food and board.
They constantly moved around.
The Midwest or the age of nine.
Trolley dropped out of school.
The transient life that he was forced to live shapes the type of boy that
Charlie would become.
He kept to himself living his life through his imagination.
He was constantly watching,
taking things in and dreaming of a future free of is no hope.
Mother,
he also learns how to become a very accomplished thief is age nine.
Charlotte was caught stealing and sent to reform school.
Three years later,
he was caught again.
This time he was off to the old school for boys in Indiana before he was taken
away.
Kathleen promised to visit him often.
Of course they never did.
It's just 10 months into his incarceration.
He escapes.
He robbed a grocery store to get some money,
and when that ran out,
he stole other things including a bicycle.
He got caught in the act of making off with the bike and soon found himself back
in confinements.
This time he was sent to Indiana juvenile center.
That's often just two days.
He stole some cutters,
freeze,
and not any himself.
That's 30 other boys.
This time,
the you on Phelan installed motorbike,
but rather a car,
but the 13 year old could hardly see over the steering wheel and was apprehended
within hours of his escape.
When he ended up in juvenile court,
he was surprised to see his mother.
His spirits were dashed.
However,
when she testified that she would not take him in the somewhat sympathetic judge
sent Charlie to Father Flanagan's boys town,
but the state hip,
it was almost too short is this last incarceration.
After just four days,
he ran off with another young offender,
Blackie Nelson.
They stole a car which they subsequently crashed cell and they made their ways
in the hands of black,
his uncle,
a world war two veteran and an underworld figure.
You gave the young hoodlums,
freeboard and food in exchange for the proceeds from armed robberies that he
happened commit during that third robbery.
The two boys were caught.
This time at Shawnee was sent to the Indiana School for boys in Plainfield here.
He stayed for three years.
Charlie would laser claim that his small statuette led him to be constantly
raped and sodomized by other inmates as well as by the school employees.
They also recalls that he was constantly picked on by the gods who would
continually find fault with him beating him with leather straps and wooden
clubs.
One night after being gang raped by her group of older boys,
he beat one of his attack as do just short of the point of death with an iron
bar.
As the boy lay sleeping,
Charlie then place the bar under the bed of one of the other attack is
successfully implicating him in the attack.
Johnny was exhibiting a trait that would characterize this personality as an
adult.
This was that he would hold his hand,
get in for a time only for it to explode later in an orgy of violence.
Over the three years he spent at Plainfield,
shawnee escaped no less than 18 times.
He was returned every time though,
and in March of 1951,
his sentence was increased and he was sent to a minimum security institution.
This was the national training school for boys in Washington DC.
Yeah.
Things were very different to what Charlie had known at plainfield.
The facility was well run.
The boys were treated well and it's a genuine focus,
was placed on rehabilitation.
Scholly liked that,
but he had no interest in being rehabilitated.
He'll do his time,
but then it get back out to the life of crime that he knew was waiting for him
at around the age of 15,
Charlene was given a psychiatric assessments.
He was found to be aggressive,
antisocial,
and illiteracy.
The caseworker reported that the boy was severely emotionally traumatized and in
serious need of psychiatric treatments.
It was also noted that he has a higher than normal aptitude for music.
On October the 24th,
19,
51,
Charlie was transferred to the national bridge on a camp in Petersburg,
Virginia,
three months later,
just weeks before his parole hearing he sodomized and other inmates while
holding a razor blade to his neck.
He was reclassified as extremely dangerous and transferred to a tough a high
security facility.
The federal reformatory at Petersburg,
Virginia.
After seven months of the federal reformatory scholly had racks up eight major
violations.
He was classified as defiantly homosexual,
dangerous,
and safe only under supervision with assaultive tendencies.
Towards the end of 1952,
he was sent to a highest security facility still that so the surprise of
everybody,
he transformed into a model prisoner.
He took lessons in reading and math and began working in the vehicle maintenance
departments.
On January the first 1954,
he was given a merit service award for his scholastic achievements.
His application to study,
sometimes a parent change of attitude led to Charlie being paroled.
On May the eighth,
19,
54,
he was putting in the care of his aunt and uncle,
but within a month of the now 19 year old was back living with his mother
ourself.
Recently released from prison.
Six months after his release,
charlie married a waitress by the name of Rosa Lee.
Gene Willis.
Shortly thereafter,
a son,
Charles Manson,
junior,
was born solely worked as a low income job or augmenting his pay by stealing
cars.
They used one of those stone and cars to me if his wife and baby,
so Los Angeles,
the car had been taken from ohioans.
Authorities were able to track it down.
Charlotte was charged with a federal crime for taking the car across state
lines.
He was given five years probation,
but when he failed to show up to a subsequent hearing,
he was arrested with this probation revoked.
Charlie was sent for three years to the prison on Terminal Island in San Pedro,
California.
After being there a few months,
he was informed that his wife was living with another man.
Two years later,
she obtained a decree of divorce.
In September of 1958,
Charlie was released on five years of parole.
He was now extending his criminal earning potential by becoming a pimp.
He had a 16 year old girl working for him.
Over the next year,
he roamed around California and New Mexico committing crimes and repeatedly
coming across the law.
In June of 1960,
he fled to taxes with a California warrants out for his arrest when one of his
girls was arrested for prostitution,
he was picked up and returned to Los Angeles to face a 10 year sentence for
cashing a forged treasury check.
At the age of 26,
he was sent to the u s penitentiary as Mcneil Island,
Washington.
While serving his sentence,
he learns to play.
The Guitar.
Ruins became interested in scientology.
During his time at Mcneil Island.
He also became obsessed with the Beatles.
Charlie has an inflated appreciation of his own musical talents,
claiming that he would with the right backing and training be even bigger than
the Beatles.
Shawnee became friends with an inmate by the name of Alvin carpets.
This form of public enemy number one was a former member of the infamous Ma
Barker gang.
He taught charlie how to play the steel guitar.
This further fueled his musical obsession and did in 1966.
Charlie's prison record is that he spent most of his free time writing songs,
accumulating 80 or 90 of them in a single later commented on the Charlie that he
knew at that time.
He recalled that Manson was a master manipulator of other people.
Prison authorities also noted that he had a tremendous drive to call attention
to himself.
In June of 1966,
charlie was sent once against terminal island.
This time in preparation for early release when the day arrived on March the
21st 1967,
he had spent more than half of his 32 years behind bars.
He requested that the authorities let him stay in jail,
but he was told that he had to leave
and so it was that the five foot,
nothing drifted with the penetrating stare and gift of the Gab wonders into the
height Ashbury district of San Francisco with $35 in his pocket and no plans
except for a desire to make it big in the music business.
Jolly moved into an apartment in Berkeley and made money by panhandling before
long year your sins and every 23 year old assistant librarian at uc Berkeley
named Mary Brunner,
he quickly one to rover and moved into our apartments.
Bronto came into Charlie's spell and he convinced her to widen out the higher.
Within a few months they were 18 young women living with them.
Charlie introduced to Mary and the other girls to drugs and before long married
quit her job and become a devoted follower of Manson.
The family was beginning to take shape with his female entourage and his guitar.
Charlie merged perfectly into the hippie culture that was then in full bloom in
San Francisco.
He refined his role as a spiritual master.
A Guru as a prophet,
he used mind control techniques.
Do you get girls to do whatever he wants it?
Most of the girls that gathered around him came from troubled backgrounds and
suffered from insecurities that left them directly,
opens at Charlie's manipulations,
as well as breaking down their inhibitions with mind control techniques.
He used LSD and amphetamines to control his ever expanding harm.
After about nine months living in and around San Francisco,
Charlie began to despair if the place it had become to overrun with African
Americans and crime was rampant.
Of course that family were doing their best to undo those crimes statistics.
They stole a credit cards and used counterfeit money to get what they need it.
They also stole a big yellow bus and painted it black
johnny and just follow his traveling by bus down the California coastline as far
as Mexico and taxes,
partying and committing more crimes after 18 months,
so extended travel.
They finally settled in Topanga Canyon near Los Angeles in a two story house.
It was here that shawnee began gathering some male members to the family.
The first was a teenager named Bobby Beausoleil who turned up one night for a
party and then stayed on this Charlie's righthand man,
but we had been staying with his music teacher,
Gary Hinman,
not far from the medicine Hyman,
but we recruited an 18 year old named Leslie van,
who teens or the family in June of 1968 around land time scholly,
and some of the gals traveled to Los Angeles where they mess up with a record
executive at universal studios,
former jail friends feel calvin had arranged the meeting.
This was Charlie's entry into the rich jet crowd and he turns on all of his
charms and make a good impression.
Seeing the family were rubbing shoulders with the rich and famous at posh
parties in the Hollywood hills in the late spring of 1968 beach boys drama.
Dennis Wilson was driving away from Malibu beach when he happened to pick up two
hitchhikers.
The girls were parts of the Manson family and they quickly agreed to go back to
his beverly hills home.
The three made love that afternoon and Wilson left for a recording session
promising to return later to take up where they left off.
When Wilson returned home in the early hours of the following morning,
he was surprised to see that a full scale party was underway.
He was greeted in the driveway by short man with a scraggly beard who approached
him,
dropped to his knees,
and began kissing his feet.
The girls who Dennis had met earlier,
I came running out declaring this is the guy and we've been telling you about.
This is Charlie inside his home,
Wilson founder.
12 more women,
most of them topless lying around and smoking pot.
Madison told him that the girls were all there for Wilson's pleasure.
Wilson was impressed with the sway that Charlie held over the women.
He welcomes the family with open arms and this phone became the regular venue
for channel.
You orchestrated orgies.
Wilson Calls Manson the wizard and began inviting.
Influential friends do come and meet him.
Dennis also allow Charlie to use anything you wanted as a Ferrari or a Rolls
Royce and all the food and drink and drugs that he or his group he's wanted.
Eventually Wilson's manager became fed up with the influence and expense that
medicine was having on his clients and Charlie and the girls were ordered out of
the mansion.
We're also spreading of the children of the rich and famous being given drugs
and having sex.
I'm Chinese direction.
Suddenly the door to the Hollywood elite lifestyle it would slam shut.
Charlie's planned for a music career was also shut down.
This coolest,
a familiar buildup of jealousy,
anger,
and rage that would inevitably find expression in violence.
Manson managed to convince the owner of a former western movie set the spawn
ranch and Chatswood not far from Topanga Canyon to allow the family to live in
the abandoned his property.
The family now moved to the ranch,
getting by by stealing and scavenging.
Johnny took to quoting.
The Bible is family members as they gathered around a bonfire during the
evenings.
He also interpreted beatle songs explaining that the lyrics were directed
towards them.
He was obsessed with one song helter skelter,
telling his followers that the song envisions and apocalypse brought on by a
race war of blacks killing whites.
The blacks would when he said,
but it would then sounds a medicine to lead the new wells
for Charlie.
However,
the revolution was taking too long.
He wanted it to happen immediately.
He began preparing family members for a series of actions that would precipitate
the black uprising.
The first step would be to release an album of music that would contain subtle
messages that would commence the black revolution.
On May the eighth,
19,
69,
Terry Melcher reproduce them,
who had met Johnny through Dennis Wilson arrived at spawn ranch to listen to
Charlie and the girl sing.
Melchert made promises but never followed through on them.
On the 25th of July,
1969,
johnny older Bobby Beausoleil sale and two women's at the home of Gary Hinzman,
the music teacher bobby used to live with Manson had had that Hinzman had
inherited $20,000 and he wanted it.
Hinzman refused to hand over the money.
Shawnee was cooled and soon arrived off.
The screening is Shawn.
He pulled out a sword and cut off his ear.
Charlie then left with instructions to get the money or kill the man.
After three days,
bobby stabbed his former teacher to death.
Before leaving,
he and the girls wrote the words political piggy on the wall along with a
panther Polo in red to lay the blame on the Black Panther movements.
Bobby Beausoleil was arrested for murder on August the sixth,
19,
69 after being caught driving around in Hinman's.
Car Manson was now ready to get his revenge on Terry Melcher,
the record producer who had let him down on the evening of the eighth of August.
He directed followers tax watson,
Linda Kasabian,
Susan Atkins,
and Patricia Cran winkle to the house where he believed Melcher was living with
instructions to totally destroy everyone in is making it as gruesome as
possible.
The house was located at one zero,
zero,
five zero clo drive,
but Melcher didn't live there anymore.
It was now occupied by a famous director,
Roman Polanski and his beautiful eight month pregnant wife Sharon tate.
That night,
Polanski was in Europe on a film project and his wife was entertaining guests at
the property hairdresser,
Jay sebring,
screen rice of Agora free,
Koski and Coffee Empire Harris,
Abigail,
Olga arriving at the property around midnight.
What's inclined to telephone pole near the Gazans?
Cut The phone line.
The car was then back to the bottom of a hill that led to the house and the
murder team walked up to find the victims.
What's an thought?
The gates might be electrified,
so he ends the girls.
Climb Day brushing embankments and get onto the grounds just then car headlights
came out from further up on the property ordering the women's aligned lying down
in the bushes.
Watson approach the vehicle.
Lynn's leveled his 22 caliber rifle at the driver that was 18 year old steven
parents watson first slashed him with a knife and then shot him four times in
the chest.
Watson then ordered Linda Kasabian to keep watch down by the gate.
He and the other two women made their way into the house.
The occupants were quickly gathered together in the lounge when asked by for
Koski who they were once in replied,
I'm the devil and I'm here to do the devil's work.
Watson then began to tie the heavily pregnant Sharon tate and Jay sebring
together by their necks with rope brought and slung over a beam.
Went sebring,
protested over the rough handling of Sharon watts,
an shot him and then stamped him seven times.
Meanwhile for Koski,
began struggling with Susan Atkins.
He repeatedly stabbed him in the legs and torso,
still managed to get to the front door,
seeing this.
What's an rushed after him meeting up with him on the porch and smashing his
head with gun,
but before shooting him twice or they go off.
Olga had managed to escape out onto the art.
She was chased by Patricia Van Winkle who tackled her and then stabbed her to
death.
The only remaining victim was now Sharon tate as she lay on the lounge room
floor with a wraparound and actually begged to be able to live long enough to
have a child,
but a police were ignored and either Watkins or Atkins stabbed her repeatedly,
including in the abdomen until both she and her unborn baby would debt
remembering Manson's instructions to leave a on the walls.
Atkins wrote the word pig with Tate's blood.
The very next day,
the family struck again this time the victims were Leno and Rosemary Lablanca
unhappy with the messiness of the previous night's killings.
This time,
Charlie went with the group to show them how it was done.
Different accounts have been given about the exact happenings that night,
but we do know that Madison was in the house and that he orchestrated the tying
up of the couple.
He then left with the orders that the couple be killed before leaving the words
war.
Rise.
Death to pigs and helter skelter were written with the blood of the victims on
the walls and the refrigerator door.
The murders caused a huge panic.
Hollywood's the pressure was now on to solve the heinous crimes.
The police got nowhere until they finally linked to the hinman merger to the
table of Blanca killings.
They knew that Bobby Beausoleil had lived with a group of hippies that spawn
ranch,
so they decided to pay the ranch and visits.
Bobby's girlfriend had told police that Charlie Manson,
the hippy girl,
had ordered the killing of Henman.
Still,
there was no evidence linking the group to the later murders.
Then in October,
24,
Manson and family members,
including Charlie,
were arrested on charges of arson and grand thefts.
Susan Atkins was also taken into custody and it was she who first began to spill
the beans.
She brags do a cellmate about killing Sharon tate,
giving a detailed accounts since implicating charlene as the masterminds about.
At the same time,
police interviewed a member of the straight Satan's motorcycle gang,
who was a madison acquaintance.
He told them the Manson had recently been bragging about knocking off five
people.
The first piece of physical evidence was the fingerprints of Patricia van
winkled that was found on Sharon tate's bedroom door.
When other pieces of physical evidence were recovered,
the police were ready to send the case to court Manson and the four people who
had committed the tate labianca murders were found guilty and sentenced to
death.
These penalties,
however it would never be imposed.
In 1972,
the California Supreme Court declared the is death penalty law unconstitutional
Manson's death sentence was commuted to life imprisonment.
Charles Manson died on November the 19th,
2017 of cardiac arrest,
having spent nearly 50 years behind bars for his orchestrating of the crimes
that took the world in 1969.
He was 83 years of age,
so I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel of a brand new biographies every
Monday and every Thursday.
Also,
I've got another channel.
It's called top tens on that channel.
As you might guess from the name we looked at all sorts of interesting top tens.
You can check it out through the link on the screen now,
but if you're looking at something else to watch right now,
why not check out a biography from the archives or top tens video over there on
the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.